[Musik]
früher ging man schlafen wenn es dunkel
war dann erfahren und 1879 thomas edison
dieses ding hier daheim sie sind
historikerin erforschen den schlaf sie
sagen die glühbirne hätte den schlaf
revolutioniert warum man kann sich das
ganz einfach vorstellen sind plötzlich
räume hell die vorher dunkel waren
das macht eine ganz neue art von
nachtleben möglich also man kann eben
nachts sowohl privat räume erhellen als
auch kneipen bars theater boulevards
straßen alles wird heller und damit
verschwimmt natürlich die grenze
zwischen tag und nacht und diese klare
idee ich gehe dann schlag wenn es dunkel
wird funktioniert im alltag nicht mehr
ganz anders und gleichzeitig kann man
durch glühbirnen die auch bezahlbar sind
die rentabel sind natürlich auch
fabrikhallen nachts beleuchten das heißt
man kann plötzlich nachts arbeiten und
damit ändern sich die rhythmen des
alltagslebens ganz entscheidend
tatsächlich ist ja einer der die
fließbandarbeit der fünten hartford mit
den sogenannten fordismus also die ganze
idee dass man schneller arbeitet
produktivität steigert der hat ja die
fabrik haben sie hell erleuchtet aber er
sagt ja auch schlaf ist überflüssig
das ist eine ganz wichtige idee schon
ende des 19 jahrhunderts also edison der
erfinder der glühbirne sagt zum beispiel
schlafen ist eine absurdität und die
schlechte angewohnheit man kann
dauerhaft wach sein man kann dauerhaft
arbeiten und diese idee kommt
interessanterweise eben gerade ende des
19 jahrhunderts außen auf und wird in
den 20er jahren nochmal viel stärker da
kommt ja auch die idee auch dass man
schneller schlafen kann also so wie man
im tourismus effizienter arbeiten kann
indem man arbeit intensiviert könne man
auch schlaf intensivieren sagen die
leute in dem man einfach schneller
schläft herbei sie sind einer der
renommiertesten schlaf forscher der welt
pharmakologe vom hintergrund her also
mediziner schneller schlafen effizienter
schlafen geht dass das geht nicht
wir brauchen den schlaf immer noch so
wie wir ihn schon seit jahrtausenden
gewohnt sind aber wir versuchen
natürlich den schlaf etwas zu
komprimieren
weil so viele anreize vorhanden sind
denn schlaf eben nicht nur auf die
übliche zeit zu in der üblichen zeit zu
absolvieren sondern ihnen etwas
anzuhängen und mit weniger schlaf
auszukommen
aber den schlaf brauchen wir immer noch
wir können auf den schlaf nicht
verzichten jetzt haben sie vorhin gesagt
wir brauchen den schlafen wir uns
gewohnt sind es gibt ja diese studien
die zeigen eben auch die historischen
studien dass man vor der
industrialisierung anders geschlafen hat
zb in zwei oder drei phasen mit einer
unterbrechung in der mitte mitten in der
nacht hat man eine geraucht etwas
gegessen man hat sich erotischen spielen
hingegeben und dann hat man noch einmal
eine schlummer phase gehabt was ich denn
normaler schlaf den normalen schlaf gibt
es eigentlich nicht also wir sind heute
eigens gewohnt an einen sogenannten
monarchischen schlaf das heißt den
ganzen schlaf in wenigen stunden
kontinuierlich zu absolvieren
es gibt immer leute die dann noch einen
mittagsschlaf einschalten das ist auch
bei heute bei uns üblich aber eigentlich
nicht in weitem maße aber sonst ist der
konsolidierte schlafen also ein
nachtschlaf bei uns der übliche und wie
sie richtig sagen frühere in früherer
zeit aber auch in anderen kulturen er
wird der schlaf aufgeteilt in mehrere
portionen also zum beispiel auch in
indien da sieht man leute auch tagsüber
auf der straße überall schlafen der
schlaf ist nicht nur ein ding das man
nachts absolviert sondern auch tagsüber
schläft man zuweilen also da ist nicht
sehr viel daran oder in japanischen
untergrundbahnen sind die leute schlafen
die leute gewöhnlich schon etwas weil
sie werden diese langen phase der
monotonie eben eher dem schlafen dann
mit
also kann man sagen normal ist dass man
schläft aber nicht wichtig ja ja das so
könnte kommen noch einmal zurück zum
thema licht sich ja interessant dass es
wenn man nächtliche satelliten bilder
ansieht das sehr auffällig ist dass in
den reicheren vermögen daran ländern in
den wohlfahrtsstaaten auch sehr viel
mehr licht brennt und schon lange ist
eben dieser zusammenhang zwischen licht
und produktivität bekannt gleichzeitig
weiß man aber auch in den hell
erleuchteten regionen schlafen die leute
weniger haben schlafstörungen etwas zu
tun mit in richtung nicht eigentlich
leute schlafen heute etwas weniger als
noch vor einigen jahrzehnten dass das
weiß man also was schlaf ist etwas
kürzer geworden aber trotzdem im
wesentlichen ist der schlaf gleich
geblieben
das licht erlaubt einfach eine erhöhte
flexibilität und natürlich auch ein
späteres zu bett gehen weil wir nicht
mehr darauf angewiesen sind zu
sonnenuntergang vielleicht noch eine
kerze anzuzünden aber dann doch bald
schlafen zu gehen
also von daher gesehen wird der schlaf
sicher beeinflusst durch das licht aber
ich würde sagen nicht so stark dass der
schlaf wirklich grundlegend verändert
haben zusammenhang eher derjenige dass
man sagt in den erleuchteten regionen
arbeitet man mehr und der stress ist
größer und deswegen so würde ich sagen
ja das denke ich auch
dennoch haben sie ja diese bedeutung des
lichts so hervorgehoben in der
geschichte wenn man hier noch einmal die
geschichte anschauen die erleuchtung der
fabriken wie muss man sich das denn
vorstellen hat man da den leuten
plötzlich gesagt er arbeitet jetzt
nachts einfach bei liegt also das haben
sie die produktionsmöglichkeiten einfach
verändert man konnte also schon das
fließband beispielsweise verändert ja
produktion zu rhythmen
man kann schneller dauerhaft produzieren
das gilt auch also für die arbeit in der
nacht die einfach bezahlbarer wird wenn
man wenn man billigere
nicht hat und was man sehen es gibt
natürlich vorher schon nachtschichten zb
in der stahlindustrie
da waren ganz lange zu zwölf stunden
schichten üblich das heißt nach der welt
gibt es natürlich schon vorher in den
bereichen der gesellschaft in denen
dauerhaft also glyphen muss dauerhaft
heiß gehalten werden damit er
funktioniert was ich glaube ich
verändert ist tatsächlich auch also wenn
man überlegt zum beispiel so was wie wie
nachtleben das sich auch in den 20er
jahren verändert je mehr leute feiern
gehen desto mehr leute müssen auch auf
der anderen seite arbeiten also im
verkehrswesen beispielsweise die leute
die bedienen müssen wenn die einen
feiern das heißt es verändert sich eine
form mit der nacht umzugehen und damit
steigt natürlich auch die der anreiz
nachzuarbeiten es gibt es gibt plötzlich
mehr zeit und wenn man arbeiten kann
weil ich diese betonung des lichts und
jetzt der möglichkeit eben freizeit zu
genießen nicht ein bisschen übertrieben
ich denke gerade daran dass wir im
letzten jahr einen schwerpunkt
katzenbeisser esskultur zum thema barock
da ging es ihm um das rauschende feste
partys die man gefeiert hat die gelage
da gab es ja noch keine glühbirnen also
erhellen konnte man die räume ja schon
ja ich würde auch nicht sagen dass das
der einzige punkt ist der sich verändert
nicht wird einfach billiger also
vielleicht könnte man sagen dass das ein
faktor ist der der viel verändert es ist
viel einfacher geworden jetzt nachts
arbeiten und ich glaube die
schichtarbeiter tatsächlich zugenommen
also die arbeit abends die arbeits
nachts ist das ist sehr stark
angewachsen seitdem fort das eingeführt
hat ist das heute in weiten bereichen
der industrie üblich und bringt probleme
mit sich
für den schlaf für die briten das heißt
die astrologie sehen das kritisch
schichtarbeit ich sehe es als eine
notwendigkeit mit der man umgehen muss
aber man muss die geschichte arbeit den
biologischen gegebenheiten anpassen also
heute arbeitet man nicht einfach zwölf
stunden nachts und dann ist's vorbei
sondern man hat gewisse schichtwechsel
von denen man weiß dass sie möglichst
günstig sind oder am wenigsten schädlich
möchte ich einmal sagen dass
also immer den die schicht nach vorwärts
wechsel dazu immer länger wird und nicht
willkürlich hin und her
das sind heute erkenntnisse die man aus
dieser schicht arbeit gewonnen hat und
die natürlich auch den schlaf sehr stark
damit beeinflussen und und optimieren
aber trotzdem inter schichtarbeit sind
schlafstörungen sehr privat und einige
großen probleme das ist ja auch einer
der anlässe gewiss gewesen weswegen
schlafforschung wichtiger geworden ist
also ich und 60er jahren auch durch den
prozess der automatisierung also viele
arbeitsprozesse laufen jetzt automatisch
gesteuert ab damit verändert sich
arbeitswelt man muss anders arbeiten
aber diese automaten können eben auch
die schlafende und ich also maschinen
funktionieren einfach durchgehen und das
ist ja auch einer der gründe weswegen
man gesagt hat
schlaf scheint ein wichtiger faktor zu
sein ja der schlaf ist wichtig aber auch
die leistungsfähigkeit in der nacht ist
eben ein kritischer punkt denn obwohl
man nachts wach ist ist man nicht
unbedingt leistungsfähig und die großen
unfälle die basiert sind an den stream
island und so weiter noch andere die
sind alle nachts basiert zu einer zeit
zu der die biologische
leistungsfähigkeit nicht sehr gut ist
wir sind also auf schlaf programmierte
in der nacht und wenn wir in der nacht
aber leistungsfähig sein müssen und uns
konzentrieren müssen wichtige arbeiten
aus wir müssen dann kann es zu problemen
kommen
und da haben sie die programmiert auf
schlafen in der nacht hat das jetzt doch
zu tun mit licht das hat zu tun mit dem
biologischen rhythmen und indirekt mit
dem licht weil licht ist einer unser
sogenannten zeitgeber für biologische
rhythmen das heißt dank dem licht sind
die biologischen rhythmen synchronisiert
mit der 24 stunden umwelt wenn wir gar
kein licht hätten dann hätten wir immer
noch rhythmen aber die würden wegdriften
von den 24 stunden meistens etwas länger
also wir würden die er den zusammenhalt
mit unserer umwelt verlieren dann
kriecht und dank an den faktoren können
wir uns synchronisieren mit der 24
stunden umwelt und unsere eigenen
rhythmen ebenfalls und woher weiß man
dass das weiß man weil meine experimente
durchgeführt hat den in denen man
personen versuchspersonen zuerst
versuchstiere man weiß dass aus der
tierforschung aber bei versuchspersonen
die lässt man werden wochen in einer
konstanten so genannten zeit freien
umgebung leben
also da gibt es keine uhren keine
informationen über zeit die leute können
ihr licht und ihren tagesablauf
selbstständig regeln so wie sie wollen
und bei solchen versuchen hat man
gesehen dass die biologischen rhythmen
weiter bestehen also es gibt nicht ein
vollständiges chaos was schlafen und
wachen sondern der schlaf findet immer
noch im üblichen portionen stadt aber
die die synchronisation mit der umwelt
verschwindet also die tage werden
meistens etwas länger und die
versuchspersonen gewinnen an versucht zu
sagen ein tag weil sie länger und sie so
weit gehen zu sagen man hat eigentlich
eine biologische eine innere uhr bevor
es eine uhr gab im sinne einer
zeitmessung ja diese biologische wurde
ist in uns drinnen und sie bestimmt sehr
viel ist vieles anders
unsere körperfunktionen sind durch diese
biologischen uhren bestimmt also auch
das hungergefühl das gefühl stoffwechsel
und unter anderem eben auch schlafen und
wachen sie haben ja bis 2006 eine
professur an der universität zürich inne
für pharmakologie und haben renommierte
teams vom schlaf vorstand angeleitet und
sie sagen eigentlich wo sie jetzt schon
so lange ist schlaf forschung betrieben
haben weiß man noch nicht warum wir
schlafen gibt es dann auch überhaupt
keine spüren
ja es gibt theorien aber wirkliche
erkenntnisse
gesicherte erkenntnisse gibt es nicht
aber da muss ich sagen die frage warum
wir schlafen ist eine schwierige frage
weil das warum kann verschiedene
bedeutungen haben
es gibt leute die suchen nach zum
beispiel nach dem schlaf zentrum das hat
man schon sein
jahrzehnten gemacht und geglaubt
irgendwelche schlaf zentrum gefunden zu
haben im gehirn und wenn das so wäre
dann wird unsere scharf impulse sie alle
von diesem zentrum ausgeben das ist
leider nicht so das gehirn ist viel
komplexer aufgebaut es gibt zwar systeme
die beim schlaf beteiligt sind aber
nicht wirklich scharf zentren dann hat
man gesagt jetzt gibt neurotransmittern
also über trägerstoffe im gehirn die für
anschlag verantwortlich sind dass
serotonin das ist eine dieser über
trägerstoffe hat man einmal so monoton
ihn genannt weil man dachte das ist
jetzt wirklich der schwach stoff irrtum
er ist zwar beteiligt aber der ist nicht
der schlaf stoff also von daher gesehen
sind die mechanismen die vorgänge tiefen
schlaf verantwortlich sind nicht
unbedingt fassbar und ich weiß nicht ob
das überhaupt zielführend ist wenn man
versucht auf diesem wege den schlaf zu
verstehen und zu kontrollieren ist denn
historisch gesehen gab es einmal wieder
momente wo man dachte mein herz gefunden
warum nicht schlafen immer wieder
also das ist das faszinierend wenn man
sich mit mit schlafforschung beschäftigt
es gibt immer wieder die überzeugung
jetzt haben wir etwas gefunden was love
erklärt also diese vorstellung dass
schlaf stoffe gibt gibt eben schon
späten neunzehnten jahrhundert da sagt
man das nennt man das hypno toxin das
sind ermüdung stoffe da sind gifte die
sich im körper breit machen und die uns
einschläfern
da hat man auch noch die vorstellung
beispielsweise dass man im schlafen ein
blutleeres gehirn hat dass man deswegen
schläft das weil das gehirn eigentlich
tot es war kein blut mehr drin ist also
alles läuft raus das sind verschiedene
erklärungsmodelle wo die immer wieder
durch die wissenschaft gehen und alle
sagen jetzt haben wir es gefunden
dann kommt von unten kommen und sagt ich
hab das schlaf der steuerungs zentrum
gefunden sind alle ganz glücklich und
sagen endlich wissen wir wo es ist und
wie es funktioniert und dass zehn jahre
später kommt die nächste idee und das
finde ich so spannend daran dass man ja
heute sagt es ist die biologische uhr an
die wir jetzt glauben und wenn man sich
die geschichte anguckt könnte man
vermuten möglicherweise sachen sagen
er versucht sich gegen den schlaf zu
impfen ja nicht das wäre natürlich das
ultimative das varianten einen impfstoff
hat der ln schlaf dann nicht mehr nötig
machen bestimmt immanuel kant sehr gut
gefahren
interessant ist ja dass ganz viele
philosophen und gerade auch die
philosophen der aufklärung um
entschuldigung die hatten ein ganz
schlechtes bild vom schlaf das vernebelt
unsere sinne wir können nicht mehr
richtig denken und wenn man im schlaf
abschaffen könnte wäre das
wahrscheinlich das erste was man tun
würde
gab es denn irgendwann der geschichte
der geistesgeschichte auch eher
intellektuelle die gesagt haben nein
schlaf ist was ganz tolles
also es gibt intellektuelle die viel
geschlafen haben goethe zum beispiel ist
immer jemand der genannt wird der zwölf
stunden schlafen musste umdichten zu
können
lösen kann ein stein ist eines der
beispiele das immer genannt wird der hat
angeblich bis zu 14 stunden am tag
geschlafen
also es gibt diese schläfer figuren
fantasien von von langschläfern die
trotzdem der sehr produktiv sind und
kreativ sind das interessante ist
vielleicht dass das gegenbeispiel immer
die die politiker und die militärführer
sind also napoleon beispielsweise der
nicht schläft und kriege führen kann
schon churchill ein weiteres beispiel
also diese fantasie des schlafens des
lang schlafens gibt es schon immer auch
die geschichte davon
es gibt beispielsweise eine literatur
auch stärker figuren aus schillers
wallenstein beispielsweise geht ab von
der bühne am ende und sagt ich gedenke
einen langen schlaf zu tun was man auch
lesen kann als versuch auszubrechen aus
dieser rationalen beherrschten welt also
er steht unter dem druck dass er alles
lenken kann
die aufklärung sagt der mensch macht
seine geschichte letztlich selbst und in
der in dem moment in dem man merkt das
funktioniert nicht
es lässt sich nicht beherrschen ist
lässt sich vielleicht auch nicht lenken
wie ich gerne möchte kommt dieser dieser
wunsch nach schlaf nach ruhe
es war in dieser zeit in der aufklärung
dass die die philosophische epoche
anschaut ja auch die sehnsucht danach
die metaphysik in das sich zu lassen
kann spricht davon dass er aus den
dogmatischen schlummer erwacht sei als
er jung gelesen habt aber die empirica
die kommen uns mit
naturwissenschaftlichen methoden
versuchen die philosophie auch ein stück
weit zu entzaubern diese dogmatischen
metaphysischen dinge daraus zu haben
und der versuch eben ohne schlaf dann
das klare denken zu erreichen
ja ich glaube es war eine beleidigung
der vernunft in einem gewissen sinne
dass man schläft dass man immer wieder
weckt 8 und dann ja sogar noch
irgendwelche während dinge träumt die
nicht nur wird es vielleicht zum teil
auch unmoralisch sind und also alle
diese dinge die sich nicht mehr
kontrolliert werden könne und ich glaube
das ist wie sie sagen tatsächlich etwas
das man eigentlich beiseite lassen warum
diese diesen teil des lebens nicht als
menschenwürdig betrachte sondern nur
wirklich das wach sein die vernunft die
ratio das war bei kant ganz
ausgesprochen obwohl kannte auch
eigentlich sich hier und da etwas
positiver über den schlaf aus hieß es
es war nicht nur seine kritik sondern
hatte er würdigt er dann auch den schlaf
als etwas also einen genuss den man
eigentlich nicht verdient hat aber doch
noch sein nach der wahl kleine sprechen
wir über heute es ist ja unter managern
spitzenpolitikern sie haben ihr ziel
bereits erwähnt ist es hier verbreitet
ständig zu betonen mit wie wenig
schlafen und auskommt und dazu schauen
wir uns einen einspieler an aus der
sendung einstein
[Musik]
sie sagt sie habe die fähigkeit schlaf
zu tanken und könne energie wie ein
kamel speichern
angela merkel schläft im schnitt fünf
bis sechs stunden pro nacht
cvp präsident christophe darbellay ließ
die nation wissen dass ihm vier stunden
schlaf pro nacht reichen die eiserne
lady margaret thatcher route zur zeit
ihrer karriere als britische
premierministerin selten mehr als vier
stunden
christine lagarde direktorin des
internationalen währungsfonds ist weder
fleisch noch bringt sie alkohol und
schläft selten mehr als fünf stunden in
dieser gesellschaft wirkt tennisstar
roger federer der sich regelmäßig acht
stunden erholung gönnt beinahe wie ein
faultier herborn brauchen
spitzensportler mehr schlaf oder ist
herr federer einfach nur ehrlich ich
glaube spitzensport verbrauchen nicht
mehr schlaf die schlaf das
schlafbedürfnis ist individuell sehr
verschieden und es gibt kurzschläfer es
gibt langschläfer die meisten leute
schlafen sieben bis acht stunden und das
ist das was der durchschnittswert ist
aber es gibt ein echtes schläfen die mit
wenig schlaf auskommen
dann gibt es aber auch schlafende die zu
wenig schlafen weil sie vielleicht von
äußeren umständen getrieben eben gar
nicht zum schlaf kommen und und sich den
schlaf gar nicht können unter glauben
ihn nicht kennen zu müssen und
vielleicht sind gewisse politiker er
dieser kategorie zuzuschreiben als aber
es gibt deutliche kurzschläfer das muss
man sehen
warum ist es so unglaublich attraktiv
von sich zu behaupten dass man mit wenig
schlaf auskommt also gerade bei
politikern würde ich denke es ist eine
macht ikonographie also man das immer
wach man kann immer
herrschen es gibt diesen dieses gedicht
zum beispiel im kreml brennt immer licht
das heißt da ist jemand der der schaut
immer auf sein volk in dem geht nix
vorbei weil er eben nur eine ganz kurze
pause macht also ich glaube schon dass
es eine macht fantasie dahinter steckt
dann steckt er natürlich auch eine
arbeits ideologie hinter immer produktiv
sein möglichst wenig schlafen mehr
arbeiten das ist ist ja auch eine
ideologie gegen den man sich ganz schwer
während kann im alltag also wenn man
beispielsweise lang weiß wie ich muss
man sich verteidigen warum schläft man
eben nicht alles hier gilt also diese
diese diese rede vom vom langschläfer
und von kurzläufer ist ja sehr hoch also
auch moralisch wo er ja ja ja das ist
das ist heute in das man mit wenig
schlaf viel leisten kann ja das ist
vielleicht der prototyp eines
leistungsfähigen manager stehen sich
brüstet mit wenig schlaf auszukommen
aber wenn man genau hinschaut tagsüber
man hat ja das gesehen in der
aufzeichnung gibt es doch schlaf
-episoden unwillkürliche die dann doch
zeigen dass der schlaf eben doch nicht
genügt und wenn man nicht wirklich im
strom steht dass man dann leicht ein
schläft nicht und doch nicht so
aufmerksam
jetzt hat der verein schon gesagt dass
sie selber acht stunden schläft ist denn
bei ihnen herr burges haben eine
fulminante akademische karriere gemacht
hatten die zeit zum schlafen
ich hatte zeit zum schlafen nicht nur
die zeit zum schlafen ich bin ein
kurzschlaf wenn ich schlafe ich schon
seit langem sechs stunden pro nacht und
wenn ich manchmal etwas länger schlafen
kann oder das mittel könne dann schlaf
ich vielleicht etwas länger aber das
sind ich bin ein kurzschluss
jetzt gibt es im moment ja diese riesige
debatte darüber dass eigentlich sehr
viele menschen übermüdet seien es gibt
ganz viele publikationen die zur zeit
erscheinen über die übermüdete
gesellschaft 24 stunden gesellschaft
verliert dann auch gesagt wenn man zu
wenig schläft wird man sehr viel
risikobereiter und das dass
beispielsweise ein problem sei an der
börse dagegen dann riesige gewinne
versuchte man da einzutreiben mit
hochrisikospielen wie ist es eigentlich
ist wenig zu schlafen tatsächlich
ungesund wie das im moment behauptet zu
wenig zu schlafen ist sicher nicht gut
und ich glaube die haupt gefährdung ist
vielleicht weniger die börse als der
straßenverkehr
es gibt leute die einigen beim
autofahren und besonders jene die eben
nicht nur selbst fahren sondern zum
beispiel buschauffeure oder andere das
sind leute die besonders gefährdet sind
und es kommen immer wieder große unfälle
zustande
die auf schlaf zu wenig schlaf oder
einschlafen am steuer zurückzuführen
sind also dass sie da sehe ich ein
echtes risiko in unserer heutigen
gesellschaft gesundheitliche risiken
gibt es auch also das kann man zeigen
dass zu wenig schlaf nicht gut ist für
den stoffwechsel für die herz kreislauf
aber hier muss man wirklich
unterscheiden ist es wirklich der schlaf
oder ist dass das leben das mit diesem
kurzen schlaf einher geht also dass
stress den man mit berücksichtigen muss
und zum teil auch die rhythmus
verschiebungen denn viele manager dies
sind die schlafen ja nicht immer hier
nur sondern die reisen ständig nach
übersee die haben jack black und auch
die politiker übrigens und diese jetlag
der ist eindeutig
gesundheitsbeeinträchtigende also zu
schlafen
zu zeitpunkt zu denen eigentlich die
körper nicht auf schlaf programmiert ist
ist schwierig und ist nachteilig wenn
man das institut also diese einflüsse
muss man mit berücksichtigt
was ich daran interessant finde ist dass
wir auch hier schlaf unter dem
leistungsaspekt betrachten man muss eben
gut schlafen um arbeiten zu können das
sind auch die beispiele die einem gleich
einfallen und schlaf als einfach als
freizeit als auszeit die man sich nimmt
mit wo man mit der man sich auch stemmen
kann gegen die den anforderungen der
gesellschaft also einfach sagen ich
mache die tür zu ich bin mir hätte ich
schlafe ich den nicht zur verfügung für
das was die gesellschaft von mir fordert
von mir möchte gilt ja beispielsweise
auch für die freizeit also ich denke
viele leute knapsen auch an der
schlafzeit um noch privatleben soziales
leben zu haben was man in der regel eben
abends erlebt also diese diese
freistellung vom schlaf als etwas das
man sich gönnt einfach auch zum zum
wohlfühlen vielleicht zum träumen zum
woanders sein
die geht immer wieder verloren schlaff
wird immer als als ressource als
leistungsgesetze betrachtet das finde
ich irgendwie diesem zusammenhang hat ja
lukas bärfuss der schweizer
schriftsteller wunderbar dargelegt in
seinem roman klar wo er beschreibt die
man das quartier das ja bekanntlich
maßen gegen die 20 stunden schläft und
auch kaum je sein lebensort wechselt
sondern höchstens mal vielleicht einen
baum weiter zieht dass dieses faule tier
ein skandalon war für die gesellschaft
man hat versucht es auszurotten da alles
so empören war das ist unfähig gibt dass
da irgendwie vor sich hin vegetiert fast
alles verdauen kann sich überhaupt nicht
anstrengen muss und offenbar und prima
vs musi volles leben führt also diese
idee schlaf als skandalon in einer 24
stunden gesellschaft in einer
kapitalistischen gesellschaft das
scheint sich ja schon so ein bisschen
durchzuziehen musste nimmt er auch
wieder ein großer diskurs darüber in
gang
richtig ja also sich den schlaf zu
gönnen den schlaf als etwas positives zu
sehen
das findet man eigentlich heute relativ
selten schlaf wird das notwendigkeit
angesehen aber nicht als etwas positives
etwas entspannendes etwas das einem das
abschalten ermöglicht eben wie sie sagen
träume
nicht mehr sich mit dem täglichen
beschäftigen dieser aspekt ist bei uns
etwas verloren gegangen
aber es wird immer wieder heute
thematisiert dass das eigentlich
irgendwo in die quere
können sie das auch verstehen ich meine
grunde genommen ist es ja so dass leben
hat so viele attraktive seiten es gibt
so viele schöne bücher zu lesen tolle
filme zu sehen
die serien die es jetzt überall gibt das
versteht man brauch dass man vielleicht
denkt ich verpasst so viel wenn ich so
viel schlafen ja man man versteht also
erstens versteht man es gerade dann wenn
einem arbeit spaß macht
natürlich arbeitet man dann auch gerne
länger das gilt aber natürlich nur für
bestimmte teile der bevölkerung
natürlich man man geht ja auch gerne
abends weg man hat ja auch die die
freude daran mal durch zu feiern lange
wach zu bleiben die nacht eben zu nutzen
das ist ja auch eine freiheit die wir
gewonnen haben beispielsweise durch
licht also dass wir einfach mehr zeit
zum leben haben natürlich ist das
unglaublich faszinierend diese idee zu
denken also da kommen auch in der
geschichte wenn man sich das anschaut
die ist ganz alt die idee dass man sagt
man kann eigentlich zwei leben in einem
leben wenn man nicht mehr schläft wir
gewinnen dritte derzeit dazu wie toll
ist das eigentlich als fantasie aber es
ist eben auch eine fantasie die die den
sinn des lebens im wach sein und im
produktiv sein und im tätig sein sid und
es gibt immer wieder zum beispiel auf
einer schlafcouch wenn ich mich nicht
irre ja leute die sagen warum ist
eigentlich das wach sein die existenz
form die wir als normal annehmen können
wenn ich auch annehmen eigentlich
schlafen wir und das erstaunliche ist
dass wir zwischendurch mal wach sind
also diese idee mal umzudrehen das finde
ich
sehr reizvoll insofern natürlich
versteht man das aber gerade wenn man es
als als anforderung versteht als
individuum ist natürlich auch eine
belastung also wir müssen dauernd aktiv
sein ich glaube der stellenwert des
schlafs wird heute nicht mehr gesehen
hat dass er eigentlich ist
wir verbringen ein drittel unseres
lebens im schlaf und das sollte wieder
eine bedeutung gewinnen
nicht der schlaf selbst der ist ja nicht
einfach nur bewusstlosigkeit da
geschieht ja einiges und gerade während
romantik hat man ja versucht durch den
schlaf zu den eigentlichen dingen zu
gelangen also im einschlafen zu sehen
was geschieht eigentlich mit unserem
geist zu welchen sphären können wir da
vordringen zu denen wir den wachzustand
leben das nicht können also das zeigt
dass im schlaf eigentlich sehr viel
geheimnis verborgen ist aber auch
wertvolles und dieses ist heute etwas in
verruf geraten bzw hat eigentlich keine
bedeutung mehr der schlaf wird einfach
als reparaturzeit angesehen um wieder
gut wach zu sein aber nicht umgekehrt
dass wir wach sind um eigentlich und den
schlaf zu erkunden sowie das sehen sie
das jetzt tatsächlich in dem dem moment
ganz politisch packen und sagen es ist
die letzte bastion die man nur hat nicht
mehr so genau
privat ist sie frei da gibt es ja einen
24 7 schlaflos im spätkapitalismus ein
fulminantes buch finde ich und in diesem
in diesem buch sagte john von prairie es
ist nicht nur der schlaf der einen
schlechten ruf gekriegt hat 20 ist
generell betrifft es eigentlich die
rhythmen des lebens also wir sind
eigentlich nicht mehr bereit felder
brach liegen zu lassen
wir sind nicht mehr bereit
ladenöffnungszeiten einzuhalten zu sagen
es gibt den sonntag an denen nichts
geschieht
diese rhythmen des lebens diese pausen
die vorprogrammiert sind die sind ja
wirklich so fast schon ein skandal wenn
man
überlegt was man eigentlich im
kapitalismus wollte sie waren an einer
stelle in ihrem buch auch das kapital
schläft nie
wenn wir diesen zusammen haben
vielleicht noch ein bisschen ausleuchten
was passiert denn mit dieser mit dieser
rastlosigkeit oder warum finden wir denn
die pausen so schlimm das kapital stadt
die ich glaube das sagt kerry auch das
eine ganz alte idee geld zirkuliert
dauerhaft bar wird dauerhaft verkauft
inzwischen eben 24 stunden rund um den
globus
man kann sich vorstellen die börse
beispielsweise läuft auch 24 stunden
muss wissen was in tokio passiert man
muss etwas gehört passiert man muss
wissen was in frankfurt passiert also
dauerhaft wird gekauft der markt
funktioniert 24 stunden am stück und
natürlich mehr passiert während wir
schlafen desto erschrecken das ist
vielleicht auch das wir schlafen man uns
zu machen und zu mir kommen wir uns
verändert es ist was passiert vielleicht
ist etwas wichtiges passiert in der zeit
also ich glaube schon dass da es ja
immer schwer auszumachen wo also wo es
anfängt wäre jetzt der die treibende
kraft ist hinter solchen veränderungen
aber ich denke schon dass man merkt dass
die veränderung von von von
lebensrhythmen und da sieht man eben
auch schon zu beginn des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts immer das nachdenken über
schlaf anregt ich werde gar nicht mal so
sicher ob wir an das schlafen aber
zumindest merkt man an dieser angst also
ich würde auch sagen dass das wovon
query möglicherweise ein indikator dafür
ist dass die angst wächst oder dass das
gefühl da ist also im moment etwas
passiert was man nicht beherrschen kann
was uns betrifft auch in unserem alltag
in unserem privaten betrifft und was
schwer denkbar ist und es ist sehr
interessant zu sehen das ist eben zum
beispiel in 20er jahren kommt die angst
vor der schlaflosigkeit hoch als leben
dior industrialisierung einsatz also das
sind phasen wo man diese angst
entwickelt und gerry weiss auch auf die
globalisierung in die natürlich dem
vorschub geleistet hat und ich glaube
auch die
die heutige internet ära ist ebenfalls
außerordentlich wichtig in diesem
zusammenhang denn wir sind ja ständig
erreichbar und ständig in verbindung mit
der ganzen welt momentan und das ist
etwas ganz neues in dieser art nicht nur
für börsen markt wird wieder schon seit
langem der fall ist sondern für
jedermann und jederfrau so dass dieser
umstand der erreichbarkeit und des nicht
ruhen der information und des
austausches glaube ich ein aspekt ist
der wiederum diese diese tendenz
unterstützt von den rhythmen eigentlich
weg zu kommen sondern eigentlich das
leben als ein kontinuum anzusehen als
eine kontinuierliche wachzeit und
ruhezeiten gibt es eigentlich in diesem
sinne gar nicht mehr
und das klingt für mich jetzt ziemlich
kulturpessimistisch das böse internet
die böse globalisierung sind sie
kulturpessimistisch ich bin ich glaube
man muss die dinge nehmen wie sie sind
ich denke das ist nicht unbedingt es ist
ein neues es ist etwas überraschendes
vielleicht man muss vielleicht
das thematisiert und dass man überhaupt
sich darüber rechnung dass man dem
rechnung trägt dass man überhaupt weiß
was da geschieht wenn zum beispiel was
ich jetzt gehört habe von
heranwachsenden dass sie nachts mehrfach
aufwachen weil sie ihr handy nicht
abstellen und uns ständig wieder
messages bekommen also das sind zum
beispiel dinge die man vielleicht doch
die ich also nicht positive anschauen
würde aber ich denke die kultur
verändert sich haben wir müssen mit
dieser kultur für diese hier ist umgehen
und wenn wir die kultur jetzt sich
verändern lassen darauf reagieren würden
indem wir sagen die alle nehmen abends
und schlafmitteln damit wir punktgenau
einschlafen können abends morgens dann
ein aufputschmittel dazwischen noch
modafinil dass unser schlafbedürfnis ein
bisschen kleiner werden lässt dass sie
vielleicht alle mit fünf stunden schlaf
zurechtkommen leere kassen
zukunftsszenario erster das möglich ist
ein zweites wünschenswert ich finde es
überhaupt nicht wünschenswert da und da
spreche ich jetzt als pharmakologe
schlafmittel bewirken zwar schlaf und
helfen in geeigneten fällen aber sie
verändern den schlaf wir schlafen nicht
den gleichen schlaf unter schlafmitteln
und ich würde das nicht ströme verändern
sich also man sieht dass aus dem hirn
strom bild das mit schlafmitteln
die muster anders aussehen es gibt zum
beispiel mit dem bekannten
benzodiazepinen die bei uns immer noch
die schlafmittel nummer eins sind
sehr viele schlafspindeln und zwar nicht
nur dort wo sie normalerweise auftreten
sondern wir als ganzen schlafs ist ein
zeichen dafür dass das gehirn funktion
verändert werden und auch dass wenn die
schlafmittel aufhören zu wirken wohl
aufhören sollen zu wirken
die wird kommt immer noch weiter geht
also man kann nicht die wirkung
anstellen und abstellen wie ein schalter
und tagsüber es ist dasselbe modafinil
und und ritalin und ähnlichen
stimulieren zwar erlauben länger wach zu
sein sich gut zu konzentrieren
aber auch sie haben und wünschte
nebenwirkungen also ich glaube eine
ökologisierung des schlaf wach rhythmus
es wird oft gemacht aber ist nicht
empfehlenswert
jetzt haben sie beschrieben dass die aus
pharmakologischer kritisch sind das hat
aber erfahren damit zu tun dass wir noch
nicht gut genug sind die richtigen
medikamente zu artikeln wenn wir könnten
wäre das nicht eine attraktive und dass
sie also viele haben sie ja also vor dem
hintergrund dass man dass man denkt man
muss dauerhaft zur verfügung stehen und
man muss sich an die rhythmen anpassen
die von einem verlangt werden dann wird
es natürlich faszinierend aber man kann
es ja auch umdrehen und sagen warum muss
ich mir eigentlich vorschreiben lassen
bis in mein körper rein also das ist ja
eine ganz ganz elementare menschliche
erfahrung zu schlafen zu träumen da
hängt ja nicht nur der körper daran
denkt die seele dranhängt das lernen
daran denken die gefühle dran
warum hat man die fantasie dass man sich
darin steuern lassen möchte von außen
von pharmakologen von experten die einem
sagen
nehmen sie doch das dann können sie
schlafen nehmen sie das dann sind sie
wach also diese diese ich würde es
eigentlich darum drehen das ist fast
schon eine gruselige science fiction
idee von einem fremdgesteuerten menschen
der bis in sein innerstes eigentlich
nicht mehr selber entscheiden kann wann
er wach ist
wahrscheinlich doch damit zu tun dass
sie ein bisschen die these von query
weiterspinnen dass sie sagen naja
kapitalismus diese gesellschaft hat zu
tun mit fremdbestimmung
aber wenn jetzt zum beispiel ein
künstler nehmen der vollkommen selbst
bestimmt durch den alltag geht und sagt
ich möchte aber nur noch fünf stunden
schlafen und noch mehr zeit so haben sie
eine tollen bilder für meine
kompositionen vielleicht um berge zu
besteigen
ich kann zumindest nachvollziehen dass
er solche erfahren dass hingibt ich
glaube dass die panzer sehen sind schon
legitimen und es gibt ja auch viele
künstler auch schon im 19 jahrhundert
die mit rauschgiften experimente machten
die verschiedene mittel einnahmen um
ihre künstlerische tätigkeit noch zu
potenzieren also nicht nur
aufputschmittel sondern auch andere
psychopharmaka halluzinogene und so
weiter also ich glaube diese möglichkeit
soll schon bestehen bleiben aber ich
glaube künstler sondern in ihre welt
einen großen freiheitsgrad haben aber
das ist doch eine kleine minderheit das
ist eben der aussteiger fantasie also in
dem moment die künstler die leute die
rausgehen auf den berg das ist ein
aussteigen aus der gesellschaft und das
gegenbild wäre ja genau das dass man
eine massengesellschaft hat die in
rhythmen steuerbar ist sagen wir mal so
ich glaube da liegt auch ein großer
unterschied ob man eben sagt ich brech
aus indem ich andere rhythmen lebe gegen
das fast die gesellschaft sonst tut also
nicht umsonst ist man eben dann künstler
oder nachtschwärmer oder partygänger
oder ob man sich eben bewegt in europa
zugänglich ist für die für die gesamte
gesellschaft würde ich auch denken dass
das nun technisch war das ist schon ein
unterschied
und sie haben die schlafmittel genannt
und das dass man vielleicht noch nicht
das ideale schlafmittel gefunden und hat
jetzt in den letzten fünfzig bis sechzig
jahren intensiv geforscht um bessere
neues schlafmittel zu finden
man hat keine gefunden wir sind immer
noch mit denselben schlafmitteln die
hervor in den 60er jahren eingeführt
wurden
und das ist für mich bezeichnen weil das
lässt sich nicht leicht durch
spezifische mitteln manipulieren
also auch da ist eine fantasie vorhanden
die man könne vielleicht ein
körpereigenes schlaf mit zu finden das
dann in echten schlafe bei führt auch da
finde ich auch diese idee ist nicht sehr
wahrscheinlich und hat keinen erfolg
gehabt dass ich jetzt auch gerade sehr
interessant fand ich dass ich vorhin
gesagt haben das kann so eine aussteiger
fantasie sein dass man eben nicht mehr
gebunden ist an diese rhythmen dass man
zb dann eben nur noch vier stunden
vielleicht schläft oder auf dem berg
sich da zurückzieht da gibt es auch die
aussteiger fantasie in die andere
richtung weiß wenn ihr an henry david
thoreau denken der 1864 dieses
wunderbare buch geschrieben hat walden
also in den wäldern der war ja so ein
aussteiger par excellence hat sich
zurückgezogen die wälder und ein ganzes
kapitel in diesem buch befasst sich mit
dem schlaf er sagt endlich kann nicht
wieder schlafen kein lärm er keine
hektik keine rhythmen also die fantasien
könnten in beide richtungen losgehen
endlos schlafen oder nicht mehr schlafen
also diese natur fantasie ist glaube ich
eine ganz starke ja ich glaube das ist
eine fantasie die werde alle in kleinen
geradeaus leben wenn wir in die ferien
gehen und plötzlich in die natur uns und
fühlen dass da plötzlich auch unser
schritt um sich wieder etwas verändern
und vielleicht normalisieren
also was ist sowie solo das schreibt das
ist schon an der steigt ja auch nicht er
steigt damit mit seinem gang in die
wälder eigentlich aus der gesamten
gesellschaft aus also er geht aus seiner
zeit raus will nichts mehr zu tun haben
mit dem was um ihn herum passiert
um wieder schlafen zu kommen können um
wieder ruhe zu haben
aber auch hier ich glaube das merkt dass
gelernt lässt sich auch zeigen in dem
text es ist zwar in seiner in seiner
natur mit seinem schlaf gleichzeitig
aber wörter glaube ich immer das pfeifen
der eisenbahn züge die fahren also die
eisenbahn wieder als schlaflose
stahl tier was durch die die welt fliegt
also auch auf ist es beides wieder drin
er schafft es eben auch nicht ganz
auszusteigen sondern diese diese gegen
fantasien das kann man will kann man
wunderbar sehen die gibt es immer die
gegen fantasie wir gehen an einen ort
der nicht modernen ist also eine ganz
antimodernen das ist immer eine topische
ort ich glaube also heutzutage gibt es
die idee man könnte eine eine krone city
bauen wo alle nach ihren natürlichen
rhythmen leben in den 30er jahren gab es
nur einen schlafsack jutta stockmann
oder schlafexperten der hatte die
fantasie man könne natur zeit schlaf
finden das hat unter anderem den
nationalsozialisten sehr gut gefallen
weil das auch nur produktivität gebe
aber der wollte natur zeit schlaf dörfer
gründen also diese idee von
phänotypischen auch wenn man hin kann
auf ihn lebt der schlaf vor mitternacht
auch zur rückkehr stückmann er sagte
dass man der schlaf vor mitternacht sei
sehr wichtig weil eine doppelzelle wenn
man vor mitternacht schläft dann kann
man mit vier stunden ausgeharrt
man muss um 1920 ins bett gehen und um
23 40 wieder aufstellung zwar mit der
airline kurzschläfer daher kommt der
kurz schlafen dann gegen auch früh zu
bett
aber alle seine schüler wurden gezwungen
den standard schafft kann ich jetzt zum
1 1 ins bett gehen habe ich schon
geschlafen sei ein einsatz leider leider
funktioniert das nicht also kann es
werden also es gibt leute nennt als
sieger an die sind ganz begeistert und
schreiben endlich kann ich arbeiten und
zwar kann ich jetzt 18 stunden arbeiten
weil ich ja nur vier stunden geschlafen
ja ja das ging mit dem
moralvorstellungen einher dass man das
ist sehr gut ist früh zu bett zu gehen
und wir ja wieder an dem moment wo man
versucht hat mit schlaf forschung
produktivität zu steigern und das ist ja
nicht nur fantasie sondern das
us-verteidigungsministerium betreibt ja
auch forschung für militärische
forschung sozusagen die untersuchen um
zb das gehirn der dax aber das ist ein
zugvogel der erstaunlich sieben tage
ohne schlaf auskommt er strikt an nachts
tagsüber sucht der nahrung erholt sie
vielleicht ganz kurz und dann wird
weiter geflogen
ist diese idee des schlaflosen soldaten
permanent einsatzfähig ich diese idee
eine vision von der sie denken die wäre
vielleicht irgendwann mit
pharmazeutischen mitteln doch in die
umsetzbar für eine gewisse zeit für
fördermittel ist es jetzt schon
umsetzbar
also die amphetamine wurden ja im
zweiten weltkrieg massiv eingesetzt von
der japaner brauch von den deutschen um
die piloten wachzuhalten das ging schon
damals und heute hat man natürlich noch
viel für andere methoden um wenn es
darum geht werden mehreren tagen wach zu
bleiben ebenfalls agogisch unterstützt
dies zu tun
es ist sehr schwer zu sagen
wahrscheinlich geht es schon gleich vier
tage lang ich kann da keine
zuverlässigen angaben machen
wenn man diese aufputschmittel nimmt
dann wirken die tatsächlich und da will
man sich nicht darum kümmert was nachher
geschieht dann kann man tatsächlich eine
längere waschzeit auf diese weise
aufrechterhalten
aber man bekommt dann eventuell schon
nebenwirkungen zu spüren schon während
des waschens also gewisse paranoide
vorstellungen halluzinationen und
ähnliches können sich dann schon
einstellen
also es ist auch nicht eine
unproblematische der sache aber diese
mittel sind sehr stark wirksam und sie
wirken und werden auch so eingesetzt und
es ist so wie sie sagen dass die vor
allem die amerikaner das amerikanische
militär finanziert schlafforschung auch
jetzt in amerika aus diesem grund weil
man sich einsichten erhofft die nützlich
sein können völlig gefühlen gehen sie in
der geschichte noch weiter zurück fiel
weiter zurück griechische mythologie
da war ja der schlaf der zwilling des
todes so hypnos und thanatos lebten
gemeinsam im hades im reich des todes
hübners in einer höhle natürlich ein
bisschen abgedunkelt damit sei man auch
gut schlafen kann diese zwillingsbruder
schafft trifft die für die fujitsu
würden sie sagen schlafen ist ein
bisschen wie sterben
ich bin noch nie gestorben
[Gelächter]
also es ist denke ich insofern ähnlich
weil man die kontrolle über sich seinen
körper seine gedanken seien
bewusstsein aufgeben muss wir können
schlafen nicht erfahren wir können
schlaf erst in dem moment der verein in
dem wir wieder aufwachen aber wie wir
uns eigentlich fühlen während wir
schlafen
das können wir nicht wissen sofern würde
ich schon sagen das ist eine form von
von toter zeit für uns man sieht
beispielsweise diese angst glaube ich
auch im schlag zu sterben
zb bei kindern kinderlieder die immer
sagen morgen früh wirst du wieder
erwachen also man muss sie wenn auch
drin ja aber diese angst dass man
loslässt aus der welt rausgeht und dann
weg ist das ist glaube ich schon was was
das was nah beieinander liegt aber
gleichzeitig hat man jetzt wie wir
lernen ja im laufe des lebens das wir
wieder aufwachen schlaf ist ja etwas
unheimlich ist alles im sinne wieder tun
oder man weiss ja nicht wenn jemand da
liegt und einfach regungslos da ist lebt
er also es gibt ja immer wieder
kontrollieren ob ihr kleinkind hat mit
weil weil der schlaf doch etwas
bedrohlich ist hat man kann nicht
kommunizieren mit dem schlafenden und
das ist glaube ich das was diese der
verbindung zum tod vielleicht provoziert
hat ich habe gerade kürzlich von mcnish
die philosophie des schlafes angeschaut
das ist ja jemand der im neunzehnten
jahrhundert ein sehr interessantes buch
über den schlaf geschrieben hat und der
erste satz ist die definition des
schlafes ist der schlaf ist etwas
zwischen dem wachzustand und dem tode
also er definiert den schlaf zu und
ja ich denke die heutige wissenschaft
würde das nicht tun aber die todesnähe
ist doch etwas was schon lange erkannt
wo sich ja vielleicht das ist ja auch
interessant zu sehen dass die wenn ich
das richtig sehe die wissenschaft das
gegenteil sagt sie sagt ja schlafen ist
ein unglaublich aktiver zustand also wir
lernen im schlaf
wir träumen unser gehirn tut ganz
offensichtlich dass das gehirn schläft
oder das ist vielleicht ein schlagwort
dass man sagen könnte
aber sie uns selber ist ja wirklich so
die ganz extreme erfahrung des
kontrollverlustes es in frage heim haben
ja auch ihr buch sogenannt kontroll
gewinn kontrollverlust geschichte des
schlafes und wenn man sich das noch
einmal überlegt finde ich sehr
interessant dass wir ja eigentlich den
tod das das ende des lebens haben ja
schon stück weit können wir das bestimmt
wir können uns jederzeit das leben
nehmen ihr können uns zu zitieren
aber wir können nicht auf knopfdruck
einschlafen das doch eigentlich eine
schreckliche erfahrung da haben wir
etwas komplett nicht im griff
ja also ob einschlafen können wir wenn
wir nicht sehr schlaf gestört sind
eigentlich nicht auf knopfdruck aber wir
legen uns hin und ihnen einige minuten
sind wir weg und das ist ja doch auch
das erstaunliches finde ich dass man
diesen übergang vom bakken zum schlafen
eigentlich so problemlos bewältigt der
schweizerinnen und schweizer kann das
nicht problemlos habe neben
schlafstörungen auch es einfach scheint
es nicht zu sein
diese kontrolle abzugeben da sind die
statistiken etwas unterschiedlich das
mit dem drittel
es ist jetzt klar eine neue arbeit
veröffentlicht wurden den drei schritten
der schweizer und schweizerinnen mit
ihrem schlaf zufrieden sind gut oder
sehr gut
ich denke da muss man aufpassen wie man
frägt natürlich haben alle gelegentliche
schlafstörungen aber schlimm wäre es
wenn man das ständig hat und das sind
dann die echten schlafstörungen aber so
im allgemeinen ist es erstaunlich wie
gut es geht wenn man das einschlafen
aber wir können ja auch nicht konnte wir
können ja eben auch nicht wach bleiben
wenn wir uns erinnern die bilder von
politikern der schlaf neben ein wenig
nur am steuer wir haben in diesem mini
schlafphasen also letztlich ist schlaf
schon eine der körperfunktionen oder
ganz grundlegenden körperfunktionen die
die ja schon wieder ständig bleiben und
sperrig weil sie eben nicht durch eine
bewusste das ist auch sehr interessant
also man entdeckt eben in also während
der aufklärung dann aber auch noch
einmal im 20 jahrhundert diese idee wir
brauchen nur den willen zum schlaf wenn
wir den willen zum schlaf haben dann
können wir auch schlafen und
gleichzeitig als das wäre
schlafstörungen hat der hat eben nicht
genug willenskraft
also wer aber diese fantasie gibt es
also auch im zweiten match nochmal war
heldenhaft ist der hat kontrolle über
schlaf der kann schlafen und diese diese
verantwortung die dem individuum damit
übertragen wird wenn du ein starker
mensch bist kannst du auch schlafen dass
das problem stellt sich heute wiederum
beim einschlafen am steuer
die frage ist ist jemand verantwortlich
dafür dass er einschläft weiß er schon
vorher etwas das er jetzt einschlafen
wird oder übermannt in der schlaf so
dass er eigentlich schutzlos
ausgeliefert ist und das hat eine
interessante rechtliche frage denn wie
isst man verantwortlich für das
einschlafen usa beispielsweise gibt es
in einigen bundesstaaten wird übermüdet
seien ähnlich gerechnet wie
alkoholisiert sein das heißt ein fluss
verantwortung er ausreichend zu schlafen
bevor man sich ans steuer setzt
interessant ist da auch wenn ihr den
schlaf schon nicht kontrollieren können
oder eben anders so überfällt dann
möchten wir ihnen wenigstens ins
privatgebrauch verlegen wir sind ja eine
gesellschaft die nicht so gerne
öffentlich schläft vielen ist es
peinlich wenn sie ein nicken im zug man
hat natürlich dann auch einige
möglicherweise körperlichen
erscheinungen die anteile sind mann
schnarcht man zuckt man mittel zugreifen
oder was sonst noch alles passiert wenn
man schläft
warum ist das in unserer gesellschaft so
währenddessen sie haben ja schon erwähnt
in japan die menschen das ja nicht so
peinlich finden oder es ist nur ein
zwang dass man da hat schon unterwegs
schlafen muss weil man sonst nicht genug
schlaf kriegt das ist kulturell
lediglich unterschiedlich ich würde
schon denken dass das kulturell
unterschiedlich ist es hat sich eben
auch im lauf der geschichte verändert
die vorstellung dass man in einem
privaten schlafzimmer schläft vielleicht
noch zu zweit als paar ist eine die auch
erst im 19 jahrhundert auf kommt man
sieht auch ein schwert 19 jahrhundert
schlafen die leute nicht privat sondern
da gibt es auch in den in den
großstädten berlin beispielsweise der
schlafen fünf bis sechs leute in einem
zimmer weil sie einfach nicht mehr platz
haben da schlafen leute im selben bett
teilweise vier kinder in einem bett
geschlafen auch nicht nur familien im
raum sondern auch sogenannte schlafs
burschen also junge arbeiter die in die
städte kommen und die nicht genug geld
haben sich ein zimmer zu leisten die
mieten sich nur ein bett und das oft
eben in privatwohnungen
also auch da gibt es diese diese schon
die die phantasie man hätte gern ein
schlafzimmer war die realität realität
sieht ganz anders aus und ich denke an
dem beispiel kann man auch ganz schön
sehen für unsere gesellschaft dass mit
inzwischen mit schlafzimmer und im bett
seien eben auch immer sexualität
verknüpft ist also beischlaf der
beischlaf man schläft miteinander als
auch das ist ja schon steckt schon im
wort drin wie eng miteinander verknüpft
ist und ich denke wenn wir die
schlafzimmertür zu machen ist das immer
auch ein zeichen dafür dass wir uns
nicht in dieses intimleben schauen
lassen wollen
ja diese aus der schlafforschung
untersuchen nun die zeigen und man
besser schläft mit anderen personen in
einem zimmer oder er gedrängt
solche untersuchungen kenne ich nicht
aber das schlafende paare die zusammen
schlafen sich im schlaf auf einander
abstimmen was ihre bewegungen begriff
sogar die schlafphasen das gibt es also
im schlaf kommuniziert man wenn man
jemandem zusammen schläft
auch in einer gewissen weise natürlich
auf es ist trivial das wenn man eine
sich bewegt die andere das spiel und ich
will ja aber es gibt da schon das paar
schlafen ist nicht einfach nur jede
schrift für sich sondern da gibt es für
auch ein kommunikatives element was ja
auch interessant ist ist in der
geschichte des schlafs wo man die kinder
deponiert in unserer gesellschaft
da gilt es eigentlich aus standard heute
dass man die kinder eher ausquartiert
aber in anderen kulturen schlafen die
kinder sehr sehr lange im bett der
eltern oder zumindest im gleichen raum
das ist eine ewige debatte gerade schlaf
erziehung von kindern ist sehr
interessant wenn man da auch sehen kann
an den tipps die gegeben werden wie man
sein kind erzieht kann man natürlich
sehen welche werte die gesellschaft auch
hat die angst die im zwanzigsten
jahrhundert aufkommt was passiert wenn
man mit dem kind in einem bachelor ist
eine tatsächlich eine ganz gewaltvolle
nämlich die dass man sein kind im schlaf
ersticken könnte also das ist eine
geschichte die findet sich in allen
schlaf ratgebern wenn sie schlafen haben
sie so die kontrolle verloren dass sie
sogar ihr kind im zweifelsfall ersticken
das ist ganz interessant es gibt meines
wissens nach keine studien die das
belegen dass die gefahr dabei größer
wäre aber natürlich spielt das eine
große rolle bei dieser entscheidung dann
spielt natürlich eine große rolle dürfen
kinder sehen was die erwachsenen in
ihrem bett tun
im privat gemacht also es gibt eben auch
beispielsweise in psychoanalytische
texas 19 20er jahren die sagen
kinderkriegen unter anderem
schlafstörungen weil sie sehen was in
den betten der eltern passiert da sie
eben bei der sexualität beobachten das
ist glaube ich ein weiterer punkt über
den also der dann eine rolle spielt bei
dieser idee bonus eigentlich das kind
schlafen diesen gebieten in den themen
green es gebe noch viel zu diskutieren
aber wir sind trotzdem am ende unseres
gesprächs es ist ja interessant sie
haben napoleon noch erwähnt napoleon
sagte ja tatsächlich vier stunden
schläft der man fünf stunden die frau
sechs stunden der idiot ich bin froh
dass endlich gesagt hat was mit den
personen ist die sieben oder acht
stunden schlafen
ich bedanke mich sehr für das gespräch
herr bei frau allein jetzt gleich kommen
wir vom kleinen tod zum großen tot
wir zeigen den zweiten teil des films
der die schöpferische kraft des todes
bleiben sie also dran
[Musik]